we got again we gotta go again
mark hey how's it going this is where
dooms is this red are you my friend I'm
drugs might run out of this recording
yes it's the best recording ever how are
you doing it back are you good how are
you good
what are you doing no you can't touch me
you're like a hunchback when you click
I'm from the matrix ha oh you got me me
oh you move like they do I've never seen
someone move so fast
hmm oh I'm stuck in your girl Hey ah the
matriarch of Morpheus baby uh what's the
name of the lady I forget already
uh uh after Emma roll Susan Susan Susan
you can't do that no no you would or no
no no call me soon son Susan adored oh I
hear a dinosaur let's kill the dinosaur
with our guns where is it probably about
to go back to his family and not want to
do it's just gathering food for it so
there it is where I don't see straight
ahead I see okay oh that died - ah Oh
God shoot it
ah you shot me what happen ahead no it
hit us
oh oh oh oh did it die God disappeared
again
we'll get it back I'm gone where'd it go
I think it's limping away like go went
back to the table well get it we need to
kill this thing
wait I'm out here scared and alone
alright I'm looking for you wait I hear
footsteps in front of me but I don't see
it I see you I don't see it where'd it
go
I don't know what wait is this a beard
did it yeah what did it like don't go in
the ocean you dingus what are you doing
in the water it's over on land it's a
light Eric went into the water
oh I see okay Jesus how did it attack
you I don't know how do we kill it
what is it healing all right it died it
died looks good at Lizzie's bone
skoo toobut / - dinosaur skin and that's
it
where'd you go how'd you get it already
oh my god where are you going I'm in uh
it's right here uh-huh
don't die on me Mountain experience I
think I saw the future we've got to
dinosaur skin now I don't even know how
you got to it I went through a land of
drugs the likes of which I have never
seen my gun left me again it went back
through your gun left you it doesn't
like you anymore oh it did they broke up
your judges love you it loves me I'm
gonna chop this rock walls here tank
Punk oh god the server's the server's
not dude - well no it is not I think I'm
getting rock I'm not sure
oh no this is going great what a great
start back to our adventures a day it
was a great start but everything's
getting too wonky yeah we were doing
fine when we were all coordinated and
they're gonna advance for this server
yeah we got guns and things just went to
hell I kind of want to go see what that
spotlights all about I just hate you I
don't know I didn't get hurt I hit the
rocket either blood Oh
Chuck's came out well maybe I'll start
dying in a few seconds lose your gun
gets back to you whit is the Sun coming
up or what has that Moodle just know
this better night for like three
galactic years Oh grand galactic yours
more than laughter here's lactic here's
solid fuse with lactic years
laughs I don't know what we're talking
about anymore uh when we're not talking
about dildos or condoms you lost me
completely I'm just out the window on
that you don't how to handle lactic
years I don't know how to handle lactic
condoms oh I don't know how to handle
great look
yeah so uh now what do we do ya know who
do we kind of did everything oh we
killed the smallest dinosaur in the game
oh yeah and that was quite an
accomplishment that we did for us it
kind of is
hmm I told you to split thank well I'll
leave if you really want me about the
wood no but I thought the douche Nuggets
we're gonna stay together forever we are
we're gonna break up wait oh I can make
I can make concrete oh I can make a
concrete platform how about I do it I'll
go get you're gonna do it you're gonna
get it I did it I got it
concrete platform where we gonna put it
right here was it green it was green for
a second hang on well we don't put it
right there that's right where our
houses
well it needs the only place where it's
green where else are we gonna get it
we're here right here where I'm at where
you're flying yes
right here no no no God no house we
can't get in oh but if they get block up
the doorway no maybe we can get in oh we
can't even get our beds out oh wait I
got my bed out your bed out I'm gonna go
get my bed yeah good luck why do we need
to put our bed inside a house anyway
like is this even oh if I put the
concrete on the bed yes you did what
were you thinking I don't know I don't
think you know I don't think I get my
bed out how do we break the concrete we
handle what we can break it come on
brick hurry my beds in there wide I'm
trying
oh you're the one that put the concrete
here I didn't mean to is your place
those grain that I get I didn't look
many other places but that's your you
didn't you took three steps what could I
have done I'm new to this game you're
the expert it doesn't take an expert to
none to put concrete in your house know
that it would clip in why would it
because this game is buggy okay fine
whatever you know I got two bullets left
they might have your name on it god yeah
I'm inside way we can get in oh crap Oh
eggy you mark come here you can get your
bed where I don't see it steep from the
ground - you sit ahead oh oh oh oh don't
get it I don't see oh yeah I got my bed
oh my god I got it I didn't know we
could
still get in here well apparently now
we're living in here like this
yes is that so bad is it really so bad
OOP my peds one right there good okay
now that we got that settled let's get
back into the game because we got a lost
track a little bit okay
now that we have a nice foundation for
our building and and the top and a bed
we can start on doing whatever the hell
comes next in this game cuz honestly I
don't know I don't lie there read more
we need a light why do it yeah we did
daylight where the hell's god damn son
hey we can get on our house now
hey dicey guys sunshine and rainbows
blown out my ass we got good stuff going
on here let's go kill a dino a big one
not just a small one but alright with
just our axe no that's just our X we're
not on a suicide mission we're actually
trying to do so my pistol keeps leaving
and I've only got two bullets left well
why do you keep oh yeah you're wait hang
on let me pull the pistol out and see if
it'll stay to me now I have two pistols
wait I pulled it out already
no I got it well then I'm what what am i
holding right now uh nothing to me Oh
got a pistol see what I got a pistol and
I got another pistol umm can wait a
minute I have a this would work I have
an idea hang on yeah I'm gonna put ammo
in here you come over here and we're
gonna pull it out at the same time okay
alright okay three two one
take it up alright did you get it I got
it but it also disappeared from me man
god damn it I thought we had onto
something why do we have two guns then
wait now it's floating in no-man's land
what what is happening over there oh
well now I've got bullets but they're
half invisible I don't know what's going
on in the game
I don't either I don't know you know I
don't find a dinosaur let's just go to
that guard tower where the light was I'm
gonna go to the light because I know
that million people have been saying in
the comments that we need to go to the
light because all right obviously light
we don't know what the hell's been going
on in our own here's a house over to the
right I don't care about that house I
care about that light I'm just saying
there's gonna be some people I don't
maybe there won't be people maybe with
your houses in the water yeah let's go
there all right
you're such a pessimist if he ever does
stop and think that me why do I think
their house is in the water well yeah
but that's pessimism or something I
don't know how winning a [ __ ]
oh it really isn't the water jeez well
um how did you make that jump I can't
just jump you goober oh I love oh well I
got in here I'm not a stamina so I can't
jump yet there's nothing here wave
didn't hear I got well how are you gonna
get out
I don't know how do I get out baby to go
I climb in that guard tower
wait oh yeah yeah oh so slow okay wait I
make this jump
wait you were so income okay wait we got
two options here all right there's only
enough there's only enough here for us
or me so what there's only enough base
here for me I claim it in the name of
our bar all right
no way you're dying I was hoping you
claimed it wouldn't know you're bleeding
oh that's gonna be hot punk oh yeah see
I never know it hurts a lot
yeah exactly so don't do it if I shoot
you in the groin with that hurt
what about what if I shoot you in the
groin also let's try it
three two what oh you find out oh that
hurt but hey Hillestad it goes back up
oh and but I don't think it tastes like
horseradish down there any moment I'm
gonna hit you with my axe okay okay ow
that hurt does this hurt no well yeah I
hurt but didn't do nothing work that or
this man does the same but my hell's
goes to back up really quickly
yeah no elbows full health again so cute
doing it okay what this oh stop it hang
on okay ow ow ah no no I didn't mean to
kill you didn't tell me you're almost
dead oh I almost did well that does why
I didn't mean
you do I get any of this stuff off
you're all God you disappeared I'll be
back my house or in the house and I'll
have my stuff on me still really is how
this works
there's no looting apparently not yeah
okay yeah I guess there is again bad cuz
my guns gone again
hey I have two guns still the sun's
coming up hey like a good to the world
we can do stuff now like oh wait that
gun that you have is magically now the
only one okay I got two I shot you with
a gun that didn't actually exist how I
don't know how do we do anything in this
game are you still down there I'm coming
back I'm coming back for you wait wait
collecting here til that Dino donors
gonna die great I died I know I don't
know how oh god why did it hurt me suck
it Dino died donger to die yeah yeah
yeah yeah yep
come on good what is it doing [ __ ] it
away there we go yeah yeah I know skin
neck is all crooked
don't worry about his neck I'd worry
about that sort of again being yeah
didn't you get on his horse game before
yeah you can have it yeah I won't I took
it I wasn't gonna give it to you hug it
good great so should we go find a big
Dino I really think we've run how stuff
to do but you're gonna fight it to your
ex where are we gonna find a D Rex I
don't know just around the Riverbend
maybe is that how we're gonna end this
series why not death by t-rex why not
you think of a better way to go well you
know honestly I cannot so where do we
find this t-rex I have no idea I guess
we just wandered let's go to the top of
that hill we can probably find it there
alright where are you I'm Beckett are
they right there yeah I'm following you
well I don't I'm out of sprint so you go
first okay uh this hill Mountain
comparatively this is like the most
boring episode so far cuz we haven't
been able to do nothing and stuff we've
been able to do no rude it up huh so you
have a gun all we've managed to do is
kill two pathetic little dinosaurs and
then I can use an axe yeah and then I
killed you here you're here
where where where over here what what
what here at the tea rice
yeah I can trust up running I'm out of
sprint get back here I will wait right
here please wait obviously Oh also it's
hard
wait okay on Thomas Mann come on up sold
at your 25 is a very old
yo sprint yet Ike it's like a quarter
God just get off my back
ah how are we gonna kill this thing well
you've got two pistols so just do wield
somehow like I know but apparently I do
have bullets why do I still have bullets
I don't know I've got this axe so I'll
hit it first then you shoot sucker
Dino burn shut up wasn't what I said Oh
ed bullets in the gun oh I'm out of
bullets now ah it's very angry my arm is
leaving me my arm leaving me wait no I
my arse my arms would away uh-oh we're
both there I'm not even joking you lost
my arms I've never seen that happen rip
my arms off what happened I don't know
it's not like stomped oh yay well not
effective
ah good job where are you on the roof
why would you on the roof
oh no don't ask me did you start there
yeah I started on the roof well huh huh
where's that Dino we will back for it I
got bullets apparently all right we'll
go for it again where is it I swear to
God my arms drifted left and floated
away
it's just like when the sky and it was
not a day I'm gonna hit him from here
all right hip suck it Dino BAM I got him
yeah no no I'm out of bullets this might
be bad get on the roof on the roof on
the roof get back close your eyes I'm
trying you know you're gonna be glad to
this concrete slab is here it's now
we're gonna be able to traverse this
baby's after you well I know that where
are you I'm coming around
why around comes straight dragons going
for me oh yeah
and I can't give a oh my god
I died can't get me die I don't know but
it can't get me oh my god wait I play
with a dino
I got a dino bad boy oh yeah do I do
we're gonna need second some dumpy or do
anything I was good at lose Dino will
you think you go give me a I don't you a
bonk on your noggin
I'm gonna bonk it snug until it falls
over bonk
stop moving your Dino there we go [ __ ]
look all right hit it from here
I'm not dying am i scream what it's not
even here let me woods right there I
swear to god this is my screen ahthe
play in the distance coming towards me
no there's a dino right here you cannot
be serious there's a forget Dino in
front of us yes there's nothing here you
are a crazy person now it's a t-rex on
its way there it is it's right here it's
right here it's what it's here and it
what are you getting in know but I'm not
hitting it either just you gotta wait
until it's like right in front of you
ah there we go oh I'm getting it now get
it good in Latin I myself am NOT ah you
just got to stand like not too close
every word careful there it's it I mean
I can see it but I can't see any damage
I am coming
ah ha hello gobby don't get too close
apparently come on oh I got it yeah see
you can't get it it's got a hold still
Ian I don't do hastert yeah oh my god we
did it what is wrong I don't know I I'm
looking up its but I don't see anything
all right
I saw something for like a tenth of a
second uh I'm reek he'll the t-rex
together yeah we did through the power
teamwork and love
maybe not love but teamwork maybe it
dropped something in our house I'm gonna
go inside wait a minute
oh that's this a table huh mark come in
here how the tour all that dead bright
ha like his face is in the way
oh I got it it's here for me I can't I
can't get in he's in the way
dinosaur flesh don't eat drop for a
second oh I got the drops I got him yeah
Arpit a kick it's dinosaur skin dinosaur
flesh dinosaur leather and ammo for
rifles nice yeah nice I can't I love it
wait how could you get in he stared at
me in the face he looks real sad his
head is where our beds are Oh great ways
for us I think we beat the game I think
we did too I think we can honestly say
we beat bisa prey you guys want to beat
beasts of prey what you apparently do is
you build a wooden house you build a
concrete slab put it in your house yeah
get on the roof you're a t-rex have a
chase you get on your roof and beat it
with an ax yep
that's how you win and there you have it
ladies and gentlemen so yeah good job
wait up we did it that the biggest bad
boy in the game yeah there's literally
none better than that oh there is it
with axes which axis so beat that
everybody this games awesome it gets our
stamp of approval triple-a minus a few
points for Wade being here but other
than that it's great right I can't think
of a better way to end it all right so
thank you everybody so much for watching
watch our seven days to die for more
stupidity check it out yeah that's
that's pretty bad too
and as oh oh and check out Wade Channel
officer yes Jeff I haven't even said
once this time check out with Shelby
wait Jail yeah check that out he's it
links in the description wait you don't
wait easily channels in my description
too if you haven't checked him out here
yeah yeah yeah so thanks again everybody
for watching and as always we will see
you in the next video bye bye
see you guys
yes I did it every bar god there's
another one